but this is something you can reason  about whereas key design 1p we don't yet  know how to reason about people working  on it for 35 years it still seems  difficult  so that is complexity any questions  about this so we're still deciding  exactly when you take six oh four six  which I hope you all will next semester  [Music]  hello oh it's uh it's companies my  collaborators have been working on this  feat versus NP problem are seriously  people's and II hope you see what this  what this means all these problems in  about our heart are some easy  cryptography McNees like Internet and  the line up hope oh my god you guys are  the first team  [Music]  professor domain has beena unstable and  we have been saying a lot a lot is very  sick you need to recover we did not join  you for next lecture first join us - we  should man